There are 19 people aged zero to 19, which is about here. And there are 21
people aged 20 to 39, which is about here. And then, five people between 40 and
59, and five people between 60 and 79. That means our bar graph will look like
this. So, we have the axis. Frequency is always on the y-axis. And then, the
variable is on the x-axis. In this case, it's age. If you recall, sometimes the
independent variable is also called the predictor variable. And the dependent
variable, which is on the y-axis, is also called the outcome. But not in this
case. This is a special type of graph called a histogram, and the variable on
the y-axis is just a frequency. Here, at the intersection of the axes is the
origin. It's Cartesian coordinates are 0,0 because from here, we've gone zero to
the right and zero up. Each axis goes from low to high. So, we start at zero and
work our way up to higher values. Same with here on the y-axis. So now we have a
histogram for our sample of 50 Udacity students.